the next thing i want to talk about
is the propensity score and propensity
space based methods for average
treatment effect destination
there are many reasons for doing this
the first is
essentially that the propensity score is
one of the most
important objects um in
observational studies and causal
inference so in a class like this we
were kind of
bound to talk about it at some point and
now is as good a time as any
the second is that propensity score
based methods
uh for average treatment effect
estimation uh
have an interesting uh connection to
machine learning and there's actually
been a lot of recent discussion
around the relevance of kind of a
machine learning based approach
to propensity-based methods so i'm going
to talk about that
and it's going to give an interesting
complement to what we just saw
in the case of machine learning based
progression adjustments
the last is that propensity score based
ideas
the ideas we see here are going to play
a key role
in enabling the kind of eventual best
practice methods
uh for average treatmentific destination
based on uh
machine learning so we kind of need it
as a preliminary for that
but anyways what is the propensity score
it has a simple definition the
propensity score
is conditionally on covariates x the
probability of receiving treatment
in a randomized trial uh you might
remember the
treatment is assigned uniformly at
random um
ignoring kind of anyone anything about
the person being treated or not
um and a way of saying this in terms of
propensity score
is that in a randomized trial the
is constant um say
in a uniform a 50-50 randomized uh trial
you flip a fair coin to determine if
someone gets treated or not
so in a trial like that the propensity
score would just be
uniformly 0.5 uh
what this also kind of suggests is that
at this qualitatively if a randomized
trial is
a setup where you have constant
propensity scores then maybe
if you look at the propensity score and
plot the spread of the propensity score
that gives you some notion of how far
a given observational study is from
being
randomized so anyways
um what's interesting about
the propensity score and the key fact
here really
is that under uncompoundedness
that is the same condition we saw in
part two
the average treatment effect can be
characterized
via you could call the inverse
propensity weighted
transformation so here what's true
is tau remember this average treatment
effect um
kind of redefined it for you just in
case you forgotten over the past
uh ten minutes um the average treatment
effect
uh you can rewrite it as um
the expectation of w y divided by e
minus the other term and this is
uh this is another representation for
the average treatment effect
um and again kind of what's interesting
about this
is that here when we originally defined
the average treatment effect it was
determined defined in terms of potential
outcomes
and yi1's yi zeros in general you don't
see potential outcomes in nature you
observe
the actual outcome y i so why is
this representation helpful well here
kind of this representation in terms of
the inverse propensity weighting
doesn't depend on potential outcomes it
only depends on actual outcomes
so this is something you can measure
whereas this is something that kind of
you can't directly measure how you need
to re-represent it
before measuring it um and so then given
this representation
what this immediately suggests is a
practical estimator
for the average treatment effect um it's
the inverse propensity weighted
estimator
takes on the following form and kind of
this unbiasedness result here
immediately tells you uh that the
inverse propensity weighted estimator
is unbiased for the average treatment
effect
ideas of this type are very common
many areas of statistics you might have
require
encountered similar idea in different
areas under a name like
importance weighting or harvest thompson
sampling
these are kind of all different
instantiations of the same idea
why um is inverse propensity waiting
unbiased
um the short story is something like
this
remember the treatment assignment here
is binary it's either one or zero
when w is one then you're always treated
so you only get to observe the y's here
when w equals one
which means that you can essentially
replace this y here
by the treated potential outcome y i one
uh same thing in the second term you
only get to see that second term
uh when w is zero when you're in control
condition
so you kind of could equivalently just
think that here
you only see the control potential
outcome
and what about this this ratio are the
remaining terms the w over e
and the one minus w over one minus e
well just remember
w is the whether you actually got
treated or not
e is the probability of getting treated
so
these ratios are 1 and expectation
so the hope is that kind of since these
ratios are one in expectation
uh they cancel out an expectation and
that's how you get unbiasedness
uh the formal argument for checking out
that this works
relies on uncompoundedness and
i kind of spelled out a more specific
calculation
here the nice thing about the
asynchronous format
is that if you want to think about this
more now is a great time to pause the
video and go through this line by line
um and if you don't the the argument the
ideas are
similar to the ones as seen earlier and
otherwise
i'm just going to keep going here
remember
all of this relies on unconfoundedness
and if you don't have uncompoundedness
then of course you need to do something
else to identify the average treatment
effect
all right so what we have so far
um is a result that here's this kind of
nice estimator temp ipw um it's unbiased
for the average treatment effect one
thing to emphasize
is that here
when defining this estimator i used the
true propensity scores
that is i actually knew i had access to
the probability of being treated
conditionally on x
for all my units so i could actually
form this score
um i'll talk about this as the oracle
estimator because of course sometimes
you don't know
efx and then you can do this and i'll
put a star up here
to remind us that in order to construct
this uh
estimator you needed to kind of have
more information about the sampling
distribution
all right if oracle ipw is unbiased
then what can we do if we don't know the
propensity score
well one very natural idea here uh
is to first kind of estimate e hat
change colors here you can first
estimate e hat
and then kind of once you've estimated
the e hats
you can plug these e hats
into the denominator here uh so kind of
this is not start this is a this is a
feasible
estimator so we're gonna kind of
first estimate e hat
this is just a prediction task right
you're trying to predict w
from x you could throw your favorite
machine learning method at it
boosting random forest deep nets
anything else
and then kind of once you have estimated
the propensity score
uh you could kind of try running through
the ipw framework kind of as though
you knew the propensity score
and this is actually if you look at kind
of
the timeline of machine learning and
causal inference this is actually kind
of
one of the first things people wanted to
do they had this idea that
look if we're running ipw uh we want
propensity scores we could get
propensity score estimates out of
machine learning
and just kind of from there proceed
the question of course is is this any
good
we know that the oracle ipw estimator
with the true propensity scores is good
is the feasible ipw estimator um
with estimated propensity scores good
now we're getting into some slightly
uh subtle territory um i won't
give a kind of comprehensive study of
tau had ipw with estimated propensity
scores
here that would be beyond the scope of
this class
but what i all i'll do here in terms of
trying to see if this is good or not
i'm going to try one line of attack that
you might hope would work
show that it doesn't go through
give up uh i won't kind of study
um tablet idw further than that um and
then what's going to happen is the same
line of attack
when applied to double robust methods as
we're going to talk about in the last
part of this lecture
then this line of attack is going to
work
so what's the idea the idea is
essentially
that this tau has star ipw the oracle
ipw estimator
if this is good then what you might hope
is that kind of estimating the
propensity scores and then plugging them
into here
that essentially it wouldn't matter too
much and if you have
decent kind of realistically accurate
e-hats out of a machine learning method
then if you
um run this kind of
feasible ipw estimator it would behave
like the oracle
then you could study the oracle in
detail um and if these two things are
similar enough then the kind of same
study would also imply some good results
about
the feasible term and ibw and if this
line of argument worked
we'd be in great shape
okay ah spoiler again i've already given
the spoiler uh this doesn't go through
um but kind of to see why it doesn't go
through let's look at this in a little
bit more detail
so this argument has to have two parts
right
first we need to have an understanding
of what does oracle
ipw do kind of
what would be the kind of ideal
properties we want this feasible ipw
estimator to satisfy and then we need to
study the gap between the feasible and
the oracle ipw estimator and kind of
argue that this gap is small relative to
stochastic fluctuations in the original
estimator
so let's start uh by looking at this
oracle
ipw estimator so this one here
um
with what we should see right is that
remember we've assumed that kind of you
your data points x
yw or drawn iid from a distribution
and also um here that this means that
if you know the propensity score
function e of x a priori
then actually this thing in orange it's
just
an average of n iid things
each of which is unbiased for the thing
you want to estimate that is tau
so now we know averages
of iodine things well right
they're gonna satisfy under very general
conditions the central limit theorem
they're going to converge at a root and
rate and so kind of once we've noticed
that oracle ipw
is just an iid average then
we're going to get a central limit
theorem immediately
and this kind of central limit theorem
is what
justifies kind of all the standard
constructions for building confidence
intervals for the average treatment
effect
um and so forth
so here just to emphasize i'm going
quickly
i'm assuming that everyone here either
has taken kind of
a first class in econometrics or a class
in statistics
uh statistics theory maybe on the level
of stats 200
um so i'm assuming that this should all
be very familiar to you
once you see an average you understand
that the average is going under general
condition satisfied central limit
theorem
and once i tell you the the central
there on the second orange display uh
you'll kind of
know how to turn this into a statement
about confidence intervals and how to
build confidence intervals
um if this isn't true i encourage you to
kind of
go go to office hours
go through what's going on with the ta
and also kind of reach out with some
more
reading materials here
but anyways so this is the oracle
estimator
the thing that converges at a one over
root and rate
what we want hope is for the feasible
estimator with estimated propensity
scores
to also satisfy this kind of behavior
and to also convert at a one percent
rate
um and what would this look like it
would look like essentially
this feasible estimator here um
we'd want this to kind of look at look
like the oracle estimator
which we're here is a perfectly fine
estimator plus an
error term the error due to kind of
using e-hat instead of e
as the propensity score metric here and
for this argument to go through we'd
essentially want this difference
uh between uh the
feasible and oracle ipw to be
smaller than one over root n to kind of
be dominated by the stochastic
fluctuations
in taoit ipw because this would then
mean that you can ignore these errors
uh when studying um
this estimator here so all right
uh if we wanted to ignore the
contributions of propensity score
estimation in ipw
we'd want this error to be much smaller
than 1 over root
n and is it now we need to kind of
try something try an upper bound uh here
i tried an upper bound
using the cauchy shorts inequality so
first
remember we want to bound this
difference tau had ipw
minus the oracle tablet star ipw
so here i just wrote it down uh what you
should notice is that here you're
dividing by
estimated propensity scores here you're
dividing by true propensity scores
the only kind of difference in how i
wrote this down is i took the outcomes
here that had
been kind of everywhere and i just kind
of
put the outcomes all to the right uh
then given this we can apply the kosher
schwartz uh
inequality it's gonna give us
this here um
you see two terms here first let's talk
about the shorter one
the square root of the average of the y
i squared
uh this is something that kind of as you
collect more data
it's not going to get big or small it's
just going to be on the order of 1. this
is going to converge to kind of
the square root of the expectation of y
x squared um
so that's fine uh the more interesting
term here is the first one
this is the one that kind of would be
zero
if you kind of use the true propensity
scores that if kind of e hath where
exactly e
how far is this from zero well
just kind of you you can go through
arguments in detail if you want
essentially the nicest thing you could
assume
is that the propensities call of course
are all bounded away from
zero and one so then you can apply some
kind of taylor expansion
and once you do this uh you land on your
feet
and you find that this difference is
essentially going to be
on the order of up to constants of the
root mean squared error of the
propensity score
so anyways this is one derivation
you could try other derivations here i'm
not going to do that
but kind of at least with the kochi
schwarz approach uh which to what do we
get
um well essentially we found that
we have an upper bound for the
discrepancy uh
between tao hat ipw and tau at star ipw
that is the kind of with a bound for the
effect
of using estimated propensity scores in
ipw
and this uh bound depends on the
root mean squared error of
the estimated propensity score is this
good enough
well the answer is going to be no
why is remember we wanted
in order for these errors not to matter
we need the discrepancy between feasible
and oracle ipw to be much smaller than
one over redundant
is this realistic uh
to get out of a machine learning method
if you studied statistical learning uh
you'd immediately see that no
uh if if you haven't uh then you'll have
to just kind of take it on faith here
uh but essentially what's realistic to
expect
in terms of rooting squared error well
if you're in a parametric problem
kind of a very easy problem where
someone tells you that kind of
say a linear model is well specified and
you just need to
fit the parameters of that linear model
then what you can hope to get in terms
of root mean squared error
is a rate of convergence of one over
square root of n
now the problems where we apply machine
learning are generally more complicated
non-parametric problems
um where getting parametric rates of
convergence
is too optimistic um and we should
generally
expect to have root mean squared error
that's much bigger than the parametric
rate of one over root n
in thinking of this you should kind of
also think back to
um our attempts at using random forests
for regression
adjustments in the previous part
where we saw that kind of random forest
will often eventually get you
the right answer um
but kind of the cost of
um being very flexible and
non-parametric means that in any
specific problem
you might converge slower so actually in
general
when you're using a machine learning
method you should always assume that
your root mean squared error
is going to be much bigger than one over
root
whereas here we kind of in order for
this bound to give us what we want
we would have needed the root mean
squared error uh to be
much smaller than one of rudin
and that essentially never happens
with uh with a machine learning method
so
okay uh this argument doesn't go through
oh of course there's um there are some
loose ends here i've essentially just
computed an upper bound and said the
upper bound wasn't strong enough
uh but it turns out this isn't the
problem this upper bound was perfectly
fine
the problem was just that kind of
a more careful study would show that
just the problem is that
ipw and star ipw aren't particularly
close in general
when you estimate propensity scores
by a general machine learning method and
that
what's going to happen is that in ipw
if you use a machine learning method to
estimate propensity scores
and then kind of
the error due to kind of plugging in
estimated propensity scores is going to
swamp
uh the sampling error you could have
gotten
by using oracle ipw
so even though kind of ipw with true
propensity scores is a good method
if you plug in machine learning based
estimates
of the propensity scores you're
generally gonna
end up in trouble
and so again kind of just to just to
restate
the main problem here is that generally
when we use machine learning methods
um what we want out of machine learning
methods is
kind of robust flexible
estimation guarantees what we want is
that kind of without having to model the
problem specifically
we kind of under very general conditions
can hope to get
consistency in large samples but
just because machine learning gives you
kind of the right answer
in very large samples doesn't mean that
in finite samples you can ignore its
estimation error
right machine learning really at a high
level
gives you predictions that are
always pretty good but never great um
and under find that in finite samples
you almost always have non-negligible
errors
of kind of when you're running ipw
when you're using a regression
adjustment as we signed the previous
part
when you're running kind of machine
running based methods here
the kind of difference in using e hat
versus e and ipw
or in many other analogous settings
um the error from using um
the kind of error from using machine
learning here is not negligible
and if you don't take it into account
you're just going to kind of
be very wrong about the accuracy of your
estimator
and so forth so generally we cannot
ignore this estimation error and the
bias that comes from it
and a naive approach that does so will
generally result in confidence intervals
and kind of other inferential statements
that are just laid off
and again why is this the case well
with ipw we just saw a very concrete
example
kind of the standard approach for
building confidence intervals in oracle
ipw
will give you confidence intervals that
are length 1 over root n
but now if you use a machine learning
based method
to estimate propensity scores you're
going to kind of
introduce an additional error term
that's way bigger that's bigger than one
over
done so kind of once you have error
terms that are
larger than the confidence intervals you
built originally
this kind of makes the original
confidence intervals useless
so okay that's all for now uh
what i hope i've gotten across so far is
that even though
machine learning methods can be used to
estimate
a variety of functions under
considerable flexibility
if you're going to use them for average
treatment effect estimation
you need to be very careful and if
you're not careful
then kind of uh that the kind of error
you incur from plugging in machine
learning based predictions into your
estimation pipeline
is just going to be prohibitively large
what can we do about it
at this point you might think the
situation is hopeless that we should
just kind of
throw out machine learning based methods
and go back to parametric modeling since
then at least
when the parametric model is well
specified uh we know what to do
but it turns out that even though kind
of naive
application machine learning method
don't work out here
there are things that do um and
and and the solution is kind of
delightful example
you can do exactly the kind of thing
we've been doing so far
that is take a simple estimator plug
machine learning based predictions in
and then attempt to ignore
the error of the machine learning based
method
the only thing is that you need to be
careful about what kind of estimator
you plug these machine learning base
predictions in and
okay regression adjustments alone ipw
these don't do the job and in the last
part of this
lecture i'll introduce an estimator that
does